when I was super poor I had a black pair
of shoes that I wore to cater and I had
a pair of sneakers that were my workout
shoes that you wore everywhere else that
I just wore right we were on Home
Improvement I remember putting the new
shoes on because they gave me new
shoes and I was like oh you forgot what
new shoes it felt like and the woman was
like you don't like him I was like no I
just and I was kind of touching him I
was like I just haven't had new shoes in
a bit she goes how long's it been I said
probably four or five years damn and she
was like what and I go yeah I just don't
haven't had the money and spending money
on the kids and you know
that um wardrobe
lady wrapped up those shoes dude
put a bow on them man that's awesome it
was it
meant it meant so much
dude it meant so much